how does immigration policy
affect uh affect housing what role is
played
is played there
i think historically
it hasn't been as necessary to focus as
much on it because you had such good
organic growth in the economy
the population but i think it's turned
into a point where it's going to be the
utmost factor moving forward because as
i mentioned the domestic population is
going to be shrinking by the end of the
decade
so everything every ounce of population
growth
is going to come from immigration
and if you don't have a policy around it
then how can in a policy of
not just a social policy but an economic
policy i think you have to start
thinking about immigration in economic
terms not just social terms because if
you start shrinking a population you
start shrinking the amount of things
people need particularly housing think
about just as big of an engine is its
housing is for the for the economy if
you put pressure on that because you
don't need more housing because you're
not growing population you don't need
more cars because you're not growing the
population you start thinking about the
ripple effect right it's an economic
problem and
the challenge i think you have is we use
some data from the pew center research
center on this is there's become more of
a polarization of immigration views
between democrats and republicans and
it's turned into a political hot button
and
now that it's in that arena
you're worried that it'll never be an
economic issue even though it should be
one
um but you also kind of think about it
from the supply side of labor here you
are complaining about most industries
about lack of labor and some of that's
social programs admittedly but there's
going to be
you know there could be a solution on
both ends if you had a policy around
immigration bring certain types of labor
here then you solve that problem
alongside
creating demand um so there's um
probably shouldn't speak out of terms
i've done a ton of economic research on
some of these things but it just
intuitively makes sense that if you have
a policy around immigration you can
contribute to the population growth as
our country has forever right that's how
we were built that's how
our population is my grandparents my
grandparents came over on ellis island
from italy so yeah sure oh exactly and
in today's
you know polish americans irish
americans italian americans were one day
thought of as troublesome for that you
know cohort at the time but they came
here they were labor manual labor they
worked hard and now there's no
differentiation on that you know living
here so
now is the time though because you
realize that
some of the stuff that we're talking
about isn't going to really bite you for
eight years or ten years on one level
you'd sit there and say we'll solve that
another day
but at the same time if you want to
solve it by the end of the decade you
kind of have to start talking about some
of that stuff now
[Music]